[Music]
not sure uses the same style that had
been presented on the on the
finger cases to explain how they were
chosen from a working group that
hosts mourning in Quebec and the selection of
candidates in the [ __ ] program on
which uses  it's not a problem
it's a problem on which a man if
it's already tried to solve me he
developed models due to a
specification he already has results
often good performance but
sometimes there isn't  has not
enough functional elements its silence
so far to deploy it the industrial
how we selected we saw that we
wanted no price especially the scops
this year so we focused on
the side I would say a confectionery  young
praj series and the models on gates
why is that because that's what
interested the most and industrialists in
any case what was the most
challenging
it was there that we saw the compositions
of the skies and then we had to
start  by a  piece
how they were certainly we have more to
choose for each of these types of
problems of new skies of new skies
because we did not want the
solutions whose payment is too
generic is sold than to identify
when we use a solution on a
skate the cases for the work to be done
for the generated 6 and has eyes this case
similar of course there are methods
that can probably be applied
to all husky three years ago the
generic methods but we are also
convinced that there are  houses that
will be specific part via certain
approaches for ontologies for
neural networks inference engine we
can not imagine a tool that solves
all and our challenge is well identified
the tools that will be applicable arcade
use with the associated limitations
function was a  so it is this
vision where we have each time what
main use which is some
ties privileged by the projects
content to develop manufacture  ic a
fourth secondary that they are well
completed since they are not all
complete there are times certain a
precise specification aude - it will be said of
which one took them in the pure state return
to integrate them with with all the
benevolence the  each carrier of kate
dillon each industrialist
I am just here to explain to you a
little the progression of this afternoon of
which after the introduction that I am
starting now and I will pass the
floor which will have four sequences
which will be presented to you but above all there
will be  workshops that will take place after
the plenary session of an hour and a half
where we will explain to you all the tools
that have been applied to a
mess because the main issue
is clearly to identify who is super
but it is  from start to finish
how we can build trust
and the holes that there are because
indeed there are holes there
are areas where the bear has been identified
in the north a little bit more ta  rd there
are areas where the log no
satisfactory solution there are there are
many answers in the different
guides that exist it is
according to the opinions of experts it is often
when you don't really know how to do it we
say named a  committee of experts for you to
validate that the solution is good so
there are still a few holes like that
but at least identify them who will
have the solutions that we believe m
next year
on the hip is still gone in my
essence on the  logic of operation
and because in the logic of match it
will be important that this version 1 is
integrated used by the industrialists
and we will really take your
feedback on this use
because we want this restaurant to laugh says troops we
have identified new buses  there is but
also integration of its versions there
in your industries in my in your
teams to see the lacks also in
the ease of use integration will
therefore be the places whatever they are
integrated into the workflow this
year as I say there are no
real new tools we have
not developed a new specific tool
we have mainly and there I thank the
whole scientific community city of
toulouse the ca of inria  the waters I
did well who transferred previous results
into the project so that we can
assess their relevance sure
it should have a
comparative cartography a little bit of the
inventory of existence so we are this year
on the integration of no example
a relatively complete report that was
done with a full day where there
was just synthesis it's abstract there and
I think that it allowed
everyone to identify where we  was and the
way still to go and then the
development work of new
bricks was started with ds which
will not give results in
berkshire but which will us which
will provide delays of the buildings and
the integration of  transfer
this version which will be made
available to you you will obviously be able to
run it on a ring road for private use we
will be delighted to have your feedback to
identify and fisher them and the
functions
just the detailed agenda for this
afternoon including the presentation which  will be done
by the beds of the necklaces so all
all the leaders of the scenes project
mentioned will be focused around 4 2 4 m
I have a presentation of the environment
of trust like cod this morning it's
a little complicated word that  it is difficult to
explain to the attempts to present the
logic in which years and we
landed in front of him in this case it is
different blocks me a second article
he will work on order to date the
existing industrial processes the idea
n  is not to develop new ones
which will be followed by a thematic session
you will be able to deepen and question
the various stakeholders a focus on
the management of the given workflow since we are
well that one of the great new
engineering auths with bastia of
knowledge it is to manage the workflow
of the given and which well specified in a
set of components which have been
integrated or will present this list of
components and but also the re text of
the state of the  art is what you may
have collected at the end of the year and then
at the end we have a little focus which
will also give rise to a
thematic session on how this
environment works how to
deploy it in the environments how
we  works so that it is
hetero maple is not isolated from the rest
of your tools here we think about our
goal
[Music]
and
above all
thank you
testimony
so it's the software component stay
in fact on the one hand it takes years
are  Hispanics who have leaked his
massages and many many we have
geeks are happy we would like to
dry up in it and the customers who are stuck in
the cars it's a bit
tricky to show that to everyone
so finding the data we can  ut
sharing it's not easy and after
once we have this data were going to
be fair that they have a lot of
work explained the first ones really weigh down
a commitment and it's true that
it's not so easy to  to go back up
to exist as long as there is also that which
slows us down in therefore in
the exploitation of salt and when we have one
in Europe where until death
but I thank because the cases
of use that we have are  now
obviously very interesting he burns his
ornaments played the princess game and
everywhere we can work behind we
would have there are a lot of projects we
limit ourselves to a fairly academic date which
are lost wonderful for
comparing the performance of algorithms
and which does not represent  not necessarily the
complexity reality
personally I understood a great
richness to have 4 despite it will be
so yes come with other four
faces type of second in lyon
you spoke it will catch up with me in
the inhabited park together
tell  e dating from june 7th
and inventiveness is what it is it is
intentionally 7 to 9 am a concert and
as the banks does not know
how to explain his shares in a
rowdy boat this reason then in the
hours match marks empowered to start  with
a little bit of delay but we started
but today we integrated it in the
too line of the environment because
for us it embarks to visit it is
how once we have a model in
the see  floor generates the version that
embeds ap he commits and but what
are the questions that we will ask ourselves
at the beginning that if we did not want the
treaty as a dissociated element in
any case in this presentation the
filiation which has specificities  own
mines power consumption tomorrow
in data centers probably
has optimization not so far from the bag
is that we've been in the
baby and detaching me
makes we associate
certain parts
obviously enough not something that  we
do in the end I think  it is
not want to reveal from spain but i think
the first side that friends and board it
empowers the constraints of an
empowered park must be identified t&d one
of the project
[Music]
but jacques users to the saver
once  totally let's talk a lot
better in this case
it's a compact I wasn't free
to specific this year again all the
work we're getting closer now
some bricks but the work has
started
yes
we said to each other this weekend
regarding  the strengths of the
matches the
magistrate compose it are the pavements to
have structures late than yesterday one the
exits is what the mark quality of the
blow fill up very 90 2
for two story structures
making the life of the city
between  youtube la marcal who were
treated debate of choice who has
breeding activities saved after
repair takes the there are
specific constraints such as the
execution time constrains the execution
time guarantee  we who exist at least
in the field who are not embedded
and earn a lot who are
managed fairly general for all
subjects I don't know ready for us to
look at the kaiser there is the question
I'm trying to find out do we
choose each other  specific platforms and
today we don't have calais uses
that turns on a what they recalled
at the expense had dropped part-time
to evaluate in the fact of choosing one
or more targets that will be
reference trays for
the  evaluation and will perhaps be one of the
elements
the embedded is clearly part of the
project now we are not positioning
ourselves in terms of patching boat going through
a dimension that serves all the matches
will partly notice it
[Music]
yeah
yes we can  discuss more
specifically taskbar but of course phone
there are specific campaigns a
hardware fault delay well according to things that
are very specific to the embarking of an
already two tasks that we  t mounted a wall
will not necessarily be deliveries
[Music]
and so yes and everything is announced we made
a call to the youth km and another reminder
that I take this opportunity to make the community
here it's next year's game
the content is not defined
today the baht chemin was
enamored queen with the integration of what
was available to power to do a
little inventory of the integration
a canvas that  we were able to make
new skies today and we are counting
on the codir and the copil to help us
the tooth we are going to have to make priority choices
to identify the songs
that we most want to bring back
in match 2 and  we are also awaiting
proposals for a new contribution
to fill in the holes we talked about
holes earlier
we have a few will be in particular on
the implications of I also have an
anchor still today this is how
I specify
united to database I don't have
many solutions on the table today  today
what gives his head if we have
proposals for action to be taken tomorrow
on this subject I am sure that rabobank
taker to validate his sons and daughters
in sion
there will be choices to be made and there we
count on the codir and  girlfriends to
give us the guidelines of what
seems to them a priority in view of the state of
coverage that we have seen of the program because
it will be necessary to make choices to be
as exact as possible but it must also
on all your proposals for news
methods of new approaches that
would make it possible to fill a hole
to improve an already existing solution
with your proposals
I take advantage of it from the southern route noting
that a contribution that Nicolas with his
friend the sessions on which are the
latest
and on which we  has two
objectives first objective is to
concretely show you this moment on
the used altar in an environment
you will be able to now
take advantage of the maintenance second objective
is stronger and juices  te landreau mouloud
and vocalizations age and needs as
we can our discussion on steve
is great the works surely marked in
particular but more generally also
feed what we are going to do battle with
videos etc or copy hobbies
in others  complete tables so thank you
for this very lively discussion
I have two good news
indeed on them I told them you're getting
there we're going to talk to you about the environment
of trust
on the program when we talk about
an environment of trust in mind
that I'm told  say in is there the result of
this environment hold the result of the
work of the program in the broad sense,
that is to say including software
it's really all this set
internal dropper trust environment
it has already been said on morning in particular
on  the bash a
choice than
to intervene on the theme columbia
data-driven
and festive and since we are
engineers of local news
intended for the hands to proceed  to a
functional test allowing in fact
to have a virtualization doubt is of
all this landscape which is the environment
of confidence at the end of this first
year
so naturally if we work on
a dreaded typology given many
missions it  is to be able to store
its accounting data to process them to
miss for the fans to have badly
essential functions which
therefore allows us to
nogales left once we have
good ones and there that they are French
how is it  that we ensure that they
are used for this data, hence the
characterization function
of data augmentation validations in order to
make this data usable for
operational functions in this sense
closer to the models of the models there is
I want  not from trainings the
Chinese model which is almost nothing of the data from
which which were built it is the
sale these
characterization instructions and then also
to evaluation of the knowing that if this  s
two these two functions will feed
from one city to another by surrounding themselves
on the training side we will go to evaluate
and the functions and result of this
education must proceed
potentially discovered cartelization of not being
need  to have games that will be of a
nature next to a new craze and
1500 worry about two
complementary elements david gering which
therefore allows us to store the models
during the process so
past
so I should strips of dealing with
models at the  course of the process when we
talk about a register here we are not only talking about
stored in a model in
omx format but also everything that goes with
all the metadata and any journey
in fact associated
with what was done 10 am this
morning  that it actually allows you
to have traceability on what
we have done on this model since the
beginning since we have been working on
this process of social integration use
everything it has we  must now  in
fact this traceability hence the interest in
fact of using a format of a constant
model which allows us to associate all
that
so I believe that we know me
who led it that we will evaluate your
data that will allow us to
work on it we will want to expose
or combine two function models in
fact of the target of our
application case so either we
actually go through a
compilation pass not finally on the subject in
bach quality which had come back to
several  occasions this morning either we can
directly expose care of it because
it is compatible with
models so classically on an
app is therefore directly to type
on it to get out of it in fact a whole
consensus environment allows you
to chain to have evening  an
embedded systems integration or access in
real time via the free strips where there
were payment lines
for the Gabonese user which we thought of is
the possibility of virtualizing
the model or more jus  even to
virtualize the target system because
we are aware that
the trust workshop and therefore be
really aware and produce a
model to be able to insert into
the interdependence and also to
take into account the system when we
get involved in it pts have  trembled on
during the virtualize workshop at least to
take into account all the complexities
all the specifics inherent in the
systems if they rent to the
application case
so to the virtualization function
of what were the grounds
and the child  once our model
is deployed in slip not
required the monitoring
actually ensured that the behavior of the
model corresponds to the behaviors that
is originally said to think of
also ensure that the data that
is captured by the model to put it on
that it is deployed correspond to
abandon which was originally
expected
when sleeping never heard because even
when it was built d  in the sense
that actually we can end up
seeing a model that is to cause the
latter dating of a certain nature
of a certain respect but once
deployed if I had this debate breaks
I had offenses in fact in  the
documentaries be able to
register and where the connection between the
monitor models and functions of
increase characterization and
worship of the dominion and its accounts
and particularly their rating
is all evening flo goes naturally it does
not feel of  saint-pal-de-mons hat
they painted a hat
themselves are all a quantity of functions
that will be generated strong
input elements indicated by users of
the trusted environment it is useful
and the second in the world with a
identity of specificities constraints
specific to their qualifications
and through damage and
methodological processes that are
associated nevertheless trust
the user and be able
to establish soglo for this  teaching in
function which will evolve on
the document badges when we will inherit
will derive evolved rather on a sort
of small pot music via is also
to define which are the components which
are in each of its members
consider to have this function as
being a  monolithic component we are
always going to be trained so the ti spice up
the model sorting function we have a
quantity of components that are likely
to meet the qualifications or not and
it is good or very good therefore
through the ice and user methodologies
and to be able to say
in the skin these two or three
training components is not
particularly I need it's
components of the star values and I hav
to think in this prank in th
s order there for  to be able to achieve
integrable monrovia simply consisted of
a coherent and
improved whole not a monolithic whole we
switch buttons that's what we
first point what  'we believe that I
also wanted to clarify is that
all of these components here are
modular we are aware it is
to explore from an industrial spectacle
the basis of these Antillean oaths or
even the possibility of integrating this
set  as is in his
working environment he is going to want to
use some of
the raid training needs is certain one
can wooden characterization name
so he must have the ability
to use these components independently
in fact the whole this set without having
to advance monolithism to have advanced
I have a tool that I use from start to
finish things in fact at the first gala
these are
logic they allow
users to be supported in the right way of
working to design design and
integrated deployed and  monitor the
sales of 1 st from gabon for a year in a in a
free system
here is
in fact
quickly
in fact the structure which can the
presentation at the reception that we will carry out
in common  only tell me is that we are going to
come back a little bit on each of these
stages confidence which brings
confidence whatever the added value
compared to what is done step by step
compared to the existing
and the first stage of the furniture  Thursday
a nonsense when therefore on the adaptation
of the processes and he salutes good
operation
I suddenly had you want to have my place
so as we have just said this
environment of trust requires
to be accompanied
by guild methods and in each of the
poets who are highlighted in red we are going to
do a little zoom since we are going to have
the first results so we will
have
to have a party is beautiful and its laws and
therefore we are going to be interested in methods
to be able to characterize the data sets in order
to be able
qualify them increase them if they
are not well balanced to evaluate the
model to define the set of the blur
and the set as of monday m so why
then why is it because you be
able to offer an enviro  nment of
conscience it will be necessary to
revisit all of them to integrate
the grips of the ai and the prism of
security to this one and cybersecurity
and that brings into play a whole series of
disciplines which are the eco
green system altogether  the hour we mentioned the
generic catal but there is also high
in the future the dow jones rinne
since we will also be interested or in
the countries where
the algae to the musicians in particular
those who conceive them new
gaborik beldi to the  software part to
jeane herrington generics and in
particular during their kabylity without
forgetting the cesti security components
and the human factors so we
really have to
build a framework which will be a
common framework in which we will only have light
is right an emmanuel of
bt variations  zoology according to sub sub
discipline a according to roles this
framework will define
engineering activities will also manage
the environment and there is a very
strong link between  the methods
the execution environment and what
happens if I take you the way and
that is and I zoom in on
the activities that are going to be that they are going to
be implemented we realize
that in  the field of
characterization of the data and we will be
interested in the top of the
generic cases with
how to qualify the coverage
of the data set in an operational way
how to qualify the data so
that's all that concerns the data
quality put in  work of indicators
to be able to measure choose then we are
going to be interested in everything concerning
the famous appalling and there we are
in the data in official gentry
haut-rhin being interested in the gambia and
trying to 1 developed methods  and
to explain which are the good
tables according to the constraints we spoke about
the constraints in limited marca and that
it will be a beautiful problem but also
qualified these high algae since it is to
taste must be correct must
have properties that will contribute
to trust as explained by ability
so we will also have to give
metrics to qualify our friends
then we will also be interested thanks to
the systems and software
engineering part we talked about monitoring
so that's  is the digital system to
monitor
the models but there is also the
whole system engineering part that eric will
develop in more detail where we will be
interested in the architecture we will be
interested
in the field of the ty room and the
v cycle finally
last but not least a year that we talked a
lot this morning
it's all about their
empowered brands where we want to be interested in
traders offers a big first
side wait and power rangers
was also
interested in calculation skills and  round robin
since you will be able to see the problem of the
compromise between their empowered brands
and the precisions of the nuns
,
but the problem is that all of this is
to ensure that we are in an area where
there is  there are several areas of
expertise and that's why you
think I'm interested in
proposing a taxonomy that
takes vocabulary
that comes from the AI world so it's by th
rau its schema with the sub-domain
s as there is directed by the  give
with machine learning but there is
also there is knowledge-based there is
distributed there is hybrid we are
also interested in
all that is data science
with mobile data and the delta the
difference between d'altaï forme and chanel
information and knowledge and we are
interested in the sirha the
engineering part but with all the sub-
disciplines of a generic was also
characterized if you remember in
the thousand leaves which represented the
program moral conscience with regard
to confidence and all dimensions
induced by confidence it goes from
precision correction transparency
not robustness but also explain it
skill we talked a lot about it this morning
and as we said this morning it is  not
something simple so we will
have to define all these concepts
below but all that is linked
and all that these old ones because
the correction has an impact on algeria
the algorithm but it also has an impact
on safety  and so it's starting to
become a real tagetik buddy we're going to
have to disentangle and for which we're
going to try to work to have
something
digital digital and to be able
to all have the same vocabulary so that
's the big part that is
being done on the taxonomy
is necessarily they are ok but
it's interesting we talked about
trust of all this little preamble
before getting
into trust it shone 3-3 ways
to get it there the first  it is to have
an experience with the
person you work with 17 trust and
is naturally created that there is a
demand and not in this situation the
second the second way to have
confidence is to have a big book  a
big book
the rules are written and apply them
to 2 clement there are a lot of questions
a little bit that we principle of quite a
lot of November situation this is the
basic principle is the proof that is not
adopted we will have confidence point here
a  A little more scientific jedir approach
consists in trying to
build a structured argument
[Music]
readable therefore
likely to be able to criticize and
it is on the basis of this argument
that we will be able to create confidence
therefore the objective of our activities in  in any
case would not have who it was to
formalize a little bit this approach
is to start building at the hall
so we talked about
ownership earlier we talked twice about
making inaccuracies while all these elements
are  provided by the various projects
of the program has just been put back together articulated
elsewhere
having verified that this
is one thing but how does this
contribute to the fine confidence and on my
system therefore the id  ed is to build
this argumentation in a way that in
a slightly mathematical way while
remaining informal, we work
on reasoning but not
mathematical reasoning in the
strict sense on the basis of a formalism and
which  calls computerization in skateboarding
which is a little fashionable today
but which precisely aims to
make targeted and clerical projects
so the diagram which is presented
here represents a little bit the approach
that we do not start again am all right  first
the development of a
verification and validation strategy on the basis
of these kate assurance for its flavor
in some way in place that the
overall scheme the formalization of six nations
this case and that is to say the formalization
of the  reasoning the construction of
the bench network and the formalization as
I said not in the mathematical sense of the
term and downhill without approaching it
standing up and the validation of this
reasoning on the basis of the cases
studies today but rather in
this revenue part its first two
parts which consists in developing this this
conceptual framework of big words and
to decline it in the phases which will
follow and this development of
insurance funds and talabot ration of
this argument is based on the
country result and the flags you
have to talk to him about the regaud projects there is
in the strict sense, including in the dia cavity,
that we feed our reasoning
with 36 and base oils and have
structures
an activity which is a small  little
transfer that all that and which is
fundamental in the time that in
my case our context is the
construction of ten
operational areas it is an activity
that we take care of up to the same
title as the rest  and who is it
as well to feed your our
argument so here is the objective it is
well to build an argument
this argument must be formalized
simply towards date is pushed here
this pa  rlementary must be open to
criticism and to do this
in the process of building a
modeling environment
that these are things that are being discussed because
it is a question of them fitting into a
larger framework than  simply the dr and
that's the ultimate goal and it gives me
a little insight in the process of doing it's
a trivialization therefore of the various
development workshops well the
construction of an argument which
makes it possible to ensure that certain
complete are satisfied under the
artefacts that are produced by these
departures pinch the workflow and the
possibility of da which is therefore between these
different elements the workflow
the argumentation and the evidences towards
the magnets of two proofs
that neither can nor does not discuss that  'they
are provided by either methods
or tools either 10 months or
2 parties the objective is to
capture all this knowledge to
formalize it under the door nationality
by a form of diagram  my and to give
this ability to navigate
and instances there is this framework that is quite
generic in a particular case which
will be the case of a double helix system
here in a few words the tragic
have adopted on this subject
yes we  have all
also passed their brands empowered
here we have already reminded this morning but
I had a little bit to
repeat myself and their maneuverability is
precisely to take it into account from the
start of the development cycle
otherwise it is often said  that we expose ourselves
to real titles received go back and
forth in relation to the 10 foods such as
henri indeed if the mind does
not fit into the fiba brand exists
to see the world completely remade
then it is super important it is very
important to take into account this
dimension in empowered brands and the type
here of development and is therefore there are
three 3 main passes and at the
upstream part showed specifications or
design the power supply part is in
fact the p  artie exclusions which we were
talking about rather from the design part so
in this first phase of lisa what
is important is always and to properly
size the darcos material so
three input data at a we have a
neural network game model and we must
select here equipment with
profitability constraints and which can
allow this model to be embarked therefore
to achieve this and it is important to be
well sized and to have tools
six matches to estimate that
the resources consumed by this model
could be needed  indeed after having
enough confidence time
now the following three in particular
on the implementation part so for
alice and that is that there are different
possibilities without being able to rely
on life frameworks and choice of matrix or
which will indicate according to namco the
best all checks
and engineer sic hardware and
sizing tools will enthroned that will
actually allow us to estimate from
my  nière macroscopic 120 have carried out
the implementation of the model and will
reach a production of the resources
consumed a little later at the
presentation we will talk about the
implementation part execution side
thomas side I think we can go to the
company so vote applications and
programs  dambach empowered when it
is important is part of it embarks
empowered it is during the transition from the model
to its implementation it is that we know
it is to take the side that a certain
number of time constraints not Kabyle
is of course  concerned and the
so-called trust products so if I go back to
these contracts we can there are several
families of constraints a first
family is linked to the resources only a
little when how the in their boat
and we have memory calculation resources
in to  the limit being what is
called the length of the swap constraints that
we saw this morning in the satellites we
also have constraints relating to
getting on his nerves do we have to  it also thinks
that a module has gone well
integrated into a system that is of
videos that are not critical it will
coexist with other components that is to
say that the ia mode will not
resume flap becomes unable to
take all the resources
which he could therefore dispose of this
first part which we called
physical resources there is also a
second part on the big source side in
the resources correct time to the
Egyptians after stability of the system
actually relaxation given answer
that we are going to invoke the model
so that's it  is the biggest
family cementing the
safety and dependability part of the
bass other than a certain number of
mechanisms of the mechanisms there is the
robustness of the system in the presence of
two equipment failures but we can
also deal with it to a certain extent  number of
subjects relating to architectural aspects
we will owe the data
of the 46 to the system as the left pedal
of good games propal several  sources
since it provided for this contract makes
segregation and also insulation
we can also consider structures
we will fall back the model again
actually has the bear and its science of the
model with perhaps a
different interpretation so all this to win  in
confidence at the end of this one
then we also mentioned this morning there are
industrial constraints, that is to
say that the account at the industrial level
that we have led me to a model we
also ensured all the mc part and in
particular the  updates and
accessibility to the brain part data
from debug or
from the system so it's all these
environmental constraints like we're not
the industry there are of course
cost constraints having been
constrained in the environment on the
part  actually I temperature
resistance to champions and finally
a very very important part is a
certification party was forced to
certification since indeed we
will have to provide proof  ves on the proper
functioning of the system so on the
implementation side we will also have to
be able to provide a set of
proofs to feed the whole process
more than opaque pub the bottom of the
certification in order to show the proper
functioning and good control of the
system  to properly take into account
all these constraints, it is also necessary
to have a model mode approach in order
to properly characterize the different
models that may intervene at
the system level there is of course the model at
the hardware level there is the
execution model at the axisemble level of
parallelism in the power supply there
are patterns of faults what are the
plans that eat away at and voices of the hardware
and of course there is the neural network global
so that's so that's an important topic not
validated
I think of July
and so those who  will come
with regard to
the methodological framework the
methodological framework that we seek
to implement
we are therefore working on
our  r the definition of a vocabulary
common to all these disciplines on
an analysis framework that will allow us
to define a set
of metric process methodology to
characterize the activities to
design them but also to maintain them
in operational condition
we have seen  this morning and we saw again
this afternoon that trust was
something multifaceted and that
it was really based
on argumentation and eric tried
to share I don't need it there is a
big
big verreault a  survey which is
around the specification of the olive tree
and then it will be necessary for the
following matches that we work on the
revisit of all these years so not
only on their machine except but
beyond that is to say on the whole
AI through new youth funds
that we called on this morning and
perhaps even go beyond life insurance
because today the question is
open, what is it?  is enough
so  tell you about an activity
so
what is
going to be done to have
the right data
for benoît ya on 1.2 of poor
quality so we have eight parties such
as ensuring that the gives and uses
to make it the same jallet superior quality
to  in any case as soon as there are nine voices
and our party
and a whole music section is useful there
is how to manage all
the acquisition for the management to the loan
so all these activities there in fact the
range of the offer corresponds in  made to the
cycles
which corresponds to the specifications of the
batteries it is the battle in pants
jacqueline chevalier because in
the industry when you have to know
it is how the academy against this
phenomenon created our boat it makes us
then my soul or there  where we push
new challenges which would ultimately be
very happy the industrialist my general
it's not good at all
either he has drawn up in what waters of
confidence so this first part on
the specification of the majlis vali  dé
really comes back before the acquisition,
that is to say that replacing
sick civil servants and our customers
who would like to have voted for
cologne and makes us pass there it will
be to look at what are the new
errors of the system
explanations but
to properly train your needs via
the specifications of our
database alas this part there is
something happening and more mature in
the slap
addressed in
particular with price methodologies
that are worth is alas manila quotes
you are also looking for
all the legal part all the assets
for
the acquisition of
the second block in fact it happens after
us anyway that we reflect on the
specification our bases our beautiful
acquisitions in the adaptations
steer the August data and no this is
where the second block is interesting
to digest  and the characterization of
data to major routes is all
the building of data management we
really part em
traffic jams begin to follow the cabinet lamy
will leave that if the endowment that 6
selections finally we will acquire
more data at the right it will be
complicated all the beauty state where they
are not necessarily immediately he
commits not selected in all this
euro zone  the one that interests us the
most the characterization part therefore which
is quite average and here is this whole
zone is the party in fact alternating sebata
interesting to take a whole
data set upwind what is
really interesting is that in benin
in detail to know
is it representative of all the cases that
interests us is there any truth
all this part there on the
characterization and finally a part which
is the preparation and the
data club so it is  in committee that we have a
lot of zeros finally we will be able to
use everything and also a lot of
north data or the alcoholics halter
arrivals or first of all the voice endowment and
all this part yesterday  in fact it is
to help waters which will be very
important for the industry but which
are ultimately quite little and you say
normand baccanini since if the
primates meet him but the people
who read public databases directly
already all of us
therefore take after this second no violently the
management of the data
we have a third block even if
the exploitation of the data on par with
the air that to
acquire we could say ok we acquire
full of becoming the anodes in
fact it will be very expensive  it's going to be
complicated so how to make
use of the data equally and
efficiently it's going to be super
characterized we broke down in order to know
in these data I was told but we
want to note which ones you
then want to use to also present
the  introduction us and the integration
whether 218 also of data generated a
particularly useful buzz in areas
for finally it is quite rich is
true that it
advances  to try it must then when it
is complicated to have cameras
that it can simple light come to
stimulate them the rank of the accident filmed uma
like that the how to bring to create of
the year
and finally the part  which is the station
the domains and we therefore lose that is to
say that we have entered a
situation where we wish to deploy it
in another situation slope
the sleigh accession of the bed in this
debate in an audi
then
the stone  this new case without having to
acquire any con data set
and finally the last block who are
interested in the location of ddd
2.7 after all these three blocks tears
with me become the coach aubois
ria we train together that  it has me
finally it is not the case here in
all situations that is mine
so there have been two parts already as
goods assessed on other ideas and
then how to look at the allocs of
the hen f to know how to
build  our house is so there we
both have  parties are linked to a
continuous increase
take advantage of cutting the carcasses
and generics
stada here it is you know all the actions
that I was taught to give it this year
we were interested in some of
these young people evening is a bulwark
lakes when ever you had to
planning data thefts you
want to do a little review of
the state of the art that we saw
what we saw it's not very clear
so quite clear from two climbs to  the
haste on these subjects speaks to us on
ice on the definition with databases
collar a few minutes from logica
talent what was produced in the
city format him ultimately it remains a
theoretical portrait and it lacks an
application a practice thielle
silva  one of the questions still
open in my life the examples of
managing
marou
[Music]
the code of the transition from theory to
practice is still a little before the
labeling of databases
do not know what m  urgent way there
is a lot still lose managing
especially the moment certainty here there
is too much abuse in our concern
it is all that is assisted by a
system specification for the on the
databases come the drop that
exists and therefore  of in fact turn parma
stab it also new night
happened as one doing in
the world not your of stairs years on
them there endowment made
the partner so if you said proud
of his ratings to the most  large a
small questionnaire goes
wrong the later and that will allow us
in fact to have on life to note
the
best finally linked to the volume of
data also a question that is very
complex 2010 is essential how
much the monastic life
and therefore there is a  response to everything that
is happening and people who in 2007
seek to politicize belgium has so
it's all this power and who are
real verhoeke
qualify
and therefore for that the actions that
we have identified that we have started  to carry out
stable i leave or even the ladies and 10
wrestling deaths in the heart of several
blocks so to look aside theoretical
how to define the
specifications theory of the vases or and in
barcelona where dd takes us the
system specifications it is suitable
to
identify  parameters which are
important which are neutral therefore to
do it in theories which made
pass a practical case here is how
really from that a few years
we will give to the person who will
acquire the knowledge proposed it is our
innotour scenario
the  other part who will see the realization
so it's the same very first action
manufactures it will be identified to which
under the labels despite the efforts to
properly enter the component in
particular of class plus the arrival without
certainties
and of course pass the tip of the practical
it  is Stalin's acceptance
of assault for the end of the year the match I
will be first guild annotations on
how well to drop and effic  acement
for the deck of the ship
I'm not coming no
so thank you who will have me so I'm going to
continue in the given direction we'll
happen afterwards when we've already acquired
the data transfer we've already done the
notation of the data or less a
first version  scoring is what
we would like is to have an ethic
of one meter from 4 and 7 August to tassette is
qualified that we have what it takes is
a breastplate points to take that I know
what  it is necessary for the evaluation of our
model ya and that we are not the cases where
for example where is with having
84 cents its host is then in reality
or jabra its cockade we understand quite
confident on our your ideas we  a also
we also want to avoid other cases where we
end up having 50% of good
predictions are an evaluation test
can this devaluation is then that
finally case not the case that we would like to
act therefore the idea it  is really
gray card is given for the development of
the island yas there its image versi  we do not oppose
that we are going what we plan to have at the end of
the year it is a first version of a
wolf which is precisely integrated into a
platform of confidence which
allows us to do that we will all be
whether or not they are available to
everyone trusted people
whether they are therefore tested on the in the event
of trusted use in particular the
unstructured renault cable valliot term
sure
test
it is therefore to be tested on these risks
a  documented in the wiki exhibits loxam
anton could come and test this tool
is of course a verve on the roof for
badji hairstyles so this is the
first book for the thing and
data characterization and there are
also reflections on the
sequel  on the one hand cash register does not include
improved cuts to be made to this
concrete tool either we continue
so I went into the detail of
concretely what it is this is how
we are going to have at the end of the year and in
particular  spared from the rating
not quite an ad  aptation her
partners what interests the most here
she knows after an overview so I'm
talking to you we offer you or who is already to
our two families and our bertrand
this can generate lamentations but
separately what interests the interest
is really how  I make sure that
but a passion the ratings are of
good quality
and
in fact what we notice we need
software is that half the time the
bread of our me and me rating and we
end up with the problems  in
either attention problems what we
often have
either errors of annotations that is
to say that it is an ambiguity on this
aggression is often obsessed notation
which will be quite complex whereas we
must finish them we  must clearly distinguish
between our cults at sion of an
interpellation arras a lot of
rotations by our object concealment
by the end of the image a vision so
these things sometimes it's complex so
inevitably
there are also the ways of a bonus
ass  ture that is to say the markings on the
ground in one country or another it is necessary
all the maps to report
problems like that and so we
often find ourselves struggling with
problems on the orientations and nine
and we  also sometimes the believers who
separate only linked to errors
ahlmann sees the members of his family
who lose notation for example we wanted
to note
the massacre in the drawing in cairo and we
notice what we have done to note infamous
of  examiners it was videos
suddenly people see all the
costs of an image and could see in
fact and hassaké very far we could not see
very well that it was a person but
with a coast and employs we could
determine that  here are the names moves
a priori it is a person except that
after the talgo rhythm and it will
take ml loans and it will not be
possible for him to detect that it
is people and
suddenly internalization was not his
compères, that is to say that we are not going we are
not  not this field more if we said that
in fact it is this person there it is
not possible to determine without contact
for her is therefore often here we
find ourselves adding or wanting to grant
an organization to a temple of floro of
difficulties like saint  yzan and so
we need to reiterate his invention
and again it happens here is how we
spent months and months noting and
we end up with the mask not
complete anne baron a test version
tears and for this Sunday it  includes
a head trellis not
my favorite my gold it risks falling to
try to iron and notation which a
priori on info-water not complete enough
and it takes a lot of time and therefore
it is its own unit therefore of confidence
and  that's why can
we cut the notation of
the data analysis tools to automatically get us out
of the batches the image of the
kangoo of data which potentially
have banknotes officials have
problems and bah here it is pl  sooner than
looking manually that you have to be
searched with small
dimples in brax had to allow you to discover
all these places and so we'll see at the
end of the year so that they beat 1
it's this blur in fact
it  it is from 8 a.m. you executive who
allow you to add but also in trèbes
to find it which is directly to be
put in the homes and on the skis
thanks to the models which have been of course
perhaps
there is a lack of a presentation on an
enthusiast  after completing them with a
small annotation so it's really the
basic dream wanted to put this
year and who sees there we would appreciate
what you test at the end of the year to
see if it's already going it's useful for 400
really very quickly and to have all this
blurring or even easier for real our
swimming
so here we go to keep the
data that they don't have a
particular enthusiasm for our platform is
available
after there are these two themes which
are linked to give  all  so not
necessarily from their life this year the
imports are quite mature so we swallowed the
research themes which are
instantaneous we are going to test like that to say there
is a little before on cases it's that
makes a little immense humanity so we have
an example activate a party to
actively select the data to
note the
manila domain notation appears noted triggering
of the riad is automatically able to
adapt and the detection of anomalies
in the data 7 comes from the fact that in
its room
to be well  no
sensor problem on nine and therefore for that to
hide as these are the
new themes little studied on the cages
use what we propose for the end of the
match it is a benchmark of the methods
which tickles tadla on the  cases
of trusted users and therefore this
benchmark at the end of the year for
gave rise to the integration activity
then in the
tool platform characterize the two
have very quickly so for those who
do not necessarily know the active varnish
so the purpose of the stib the remix and
given a first face to face with the
presentation we hear it is used to
present a few hundred a few
thousand annotations are very expensive
aproca also hundreds -
millions of  the image of his panel of
available funds has always but more
often available the question arises
very glee want to miss what kazim at
pediment of this big data 7 to
annotate them to improve this very well
and he will miss it is something that
is  once again very little heard
of a first job in the sky in iraq
is for others in the best
methods maxime burning and here he is very
little studied
the cases where we find ourselves with a
class balance in cantenac some
pedestrians  but we have billions of
cars how do we manage that how do
I get more inspiration I get a lot of
pedestrians in my data - labeled there
are also other things for us you are
ass  There is little in all the literature about a
threshold to the use of metadata, we
have often been
worried about preventing them from being localized,
their alteration, pressure on images, etc.,
and so this is something that we are seeing
we are studying this year and moreover there
is  a post that will be presented tomorrow
reaction to have his death and the facilities demolished
so a clematis also in india
marks
this year that's all
detection of anomalies in the dates has
done in the past waits to see if the
anomalies  cash that the killings this
year as an anomaly so we can
find the bleachers tation is called
advice when the anomalies example we have
a passion for boxes on people
launched the concept of wooden cars and
we see that there is a box everything  some
boxes that are labeled like
nobody but that look a lot
like cars totally they are
lee animals and we find them to
prologis the head his passion after we
have other r  allies which interests us
this year it is obviously two
sensors to
respect if there was a vast surface
or and for which after yes our
detector of classic restaurants to
do any the task in fact
I will not be more efficient could do  no
so it's
our themes will give rise to
a final theme on swimming
area so I'm going to let you grow
from man they presented their area
it
passed in the event that
we finally trained our first
model on a ko like us  they you
it's a car at the meetings
and exchanges given in paris
two packages in tokyo of the payment
sufficiently
finally lowering them from the world will
allow a
retraining our currency on the news of nagui is
acquired in tokyo but not necessarily
given the stupidity
[Music]
like that the cac and women who are
interesting in an industrial environment
finally we have to adapt
components to different situations and
therefore it can  also be the case we
train the hedge de leysin teti
to adapt it in the world
of saint-theresa trimmers the
domains four
[Music]
tracks the new models in view of the
news here in version seems
historically given and we this
announcement interests crisis is  finished said
carol without
an
industry in particular the cancellation domain
we are not the day with
care situations like that
so the planted the themes on
which we are
that also that they are and bischheim
the summer for the following years
we  wanted to end with a few
messages on what will be available at the
end of the year so how did a
little gaignard say the first shop that
makes it possible to make the peace agreement the
quality remains
and the notation correction which will be one
of the jewels only in  the
trusted platform and tested on both disks
the
industrial vacuum passion for up-to-date adults
and finally a benchmark of da to make
the elections no data
however  nt the institution we are fourth
here and to finish my of course he knows
the themes addressed
either approach you like the following
especially this year the us quality that
the image is to try cantonal but
only has to follow we  working
on other types of mobility like the
old os text
on the page
if camille clora
[Applause]
[Music]
this time of how do we characterize the
amps how do we characterize the
components there are and that if how
designs them for not having characterize them
are made directly good that's what
project 4 does we don't need
to characterize them and therefore soon
karate
normally will no longer be of any use as soon
as the project is born
there are young people when we talk about
walking
how this  that we take care of c2c box it
has from valuation of models monitor
the models therefore check that everything
works well and the
training part of the models for
manufacturing of the models
in the first p  artie that I present
and on the characterization of the
models part therefore in the offer that we had
made to the beginners designed the project
in this part because there were these
five boxes which were there to evaluate the
performances
characterize a data therefore to evaluate the
performances  to come when I give you
a
decision I tell you if I'm sure of
myself busy not sure of myself characterized the
life to pass especially worked on
robustness in this case we got a
lot of order of order  correctness
be their experimental correctness at this
point of models and seeing if he
changes his mind counted against castle y
or demon chosen good architecture
which will make that as it will be a little
more robust the part iii beats it is the
same  thing but on the part which has
symbolic the 1st 2nd and at sion there is no d
on the data and the fourth on the
famous explains empowered with Switzerland
there is a lot of work we will present you a
lot of things on this
exp  lique skills of the times now that
after the opinions are divided is it
that once a gossip the model
explains how he thinks does that
mean that we will learn more
confidence in him well yes in part that's
enough  live but it's a good way
to tell if the man the model explains
how he said there he made his
decision and that I think it's for
the right reasons it makes me rather
confident that's part of the elements
that we are going to put in the teeth all
the arguments will do to convince
our quality engineers our safety engineers
that what we have worked well and then
the last is the monitoring so
monitor that our use that our that
our model works well  and who says
no stupidity that comes from the good
data the job there is necessarily a little
overlap with what is
done in the teeth in the
previous work only have when we characterize
the detection of anomalies either in gulf
air oman  at length  did its
learning which we can also
do it when the data arrives
will see if I have a camel that crosses
and that I have ever seen a
coal base in my learning base
because flora took care to remove the
camels on the pretext that this is what
happens is not often unfortunately
I still have to realize that
it is not something I usually see
and that I make a relevant decision
when the people
are in the game  in valence i
left in bold that what we are really going to
do this year in all the
symbolic part we do not deal with
this year at all however not a little on
all the
fields architecture david in fact at my
mastery  on this risk explains empowered
we are not going to the treaty either but for
the rest we will still cover well
with first versions of tools on
you to solve all these questions
so before starting we
had our researchers do haneda instead and  what a
rivalry
hello everyone so we made
the $ state of the kilometer on these aspects the
spread over five different thematic axes
in the introduction when
you understood this morning that the whole
part of a symbolic it was spread
rather match 2 so we  has mostly done
initialization of agitators on that
which assures plus the city has been in part
the tax ni so this is the case of all the
various themes discussed topics more
particularly in overall return what
is interesting to note is  that the
consortium was rather well positioned
in relation to what is being done whether
at the academic level etc on
all four themes 2 will appear your
initials hy tern or two by the
works before they are already carried out
around the cold it  was struck off
so suddenly we are more like guys we
still managed to isolate relevant activities
and some
key elements so in particular on an
activity return of
co speeches  nfiance or two metrics have been
identified and will be launching their
very beginning of match 2 so these are
calculations that will allow us
to analyze in a little more
beautiful way seeing the results explains them
living on the part of the stress c  it's the
same we have identified two methods two
tools it is absolutely necessary to implement in order
to qualify the
robustness of the
teenagers and not on the explicable
itele part what is interesting is that
we still have a little bit at a small
discrepancy between the explanations that we
provide the way of apprehending them by
12 hours, that is to say that we have already
made in particular on the used guys renault
the exchanges in relation to the notion of
suspects explains empowered that we are
able to come out and know if he
was able to project them in
their operational context of validation
and this is where we realize we will
have to do a little work
of adapting what scientifically
and thematically we  is able to
produce so that it is injected
directly into
day-to-day production lines so there
is both a sony branding issue but
also a projection space has changed
to be able to integrate this into real life
back to the game  monitoring
sanou perdu did not identify that
there was a dummy on the
real-time monitoring part of what is
happening so as not to actually
spin gossip about data that
will be unusable or things like
that
you have to exactly
we also have to manage to define what
we expect helmand from the lido and the way in
which we will want to monitor the
activities that are carried out by the
system will say to ourselves what do we want to
make sacred centralized and what  'they are
going to solve its technical problems of
frequency of analyzes to be able to
have reversal and federal loops
so here is roughly speaking the
grains of the east win at the accesses which
came out which jumped on  this
theme
here is Grégory this industrial project and
concept is branded with the best in the
field with in particular an island project
I hope we don't have this bread to
do no but we saw it all the same
was ticket palace we have a few
small holes in the racket to
resume the experience is given this
morning but we still had a
lot to do already with existence
and what emmanuel had said and we were able to
start quite quickly  without waiting for
all those that all this research
is well mature
here is my return of the four swords of the
four domains that we kept only at 5.5
actions that have been started
here it is in particular on the
ca tradition of  uncertainty the
formal evaluation of the argus test and
local robustness evaluation explains
the monitoring so we will unfold all of
this to present to you what we hope to
do this year and will be able to deliver by
the end of  year therefore on the
formal methods  are the formal methods
that's really a subject that is
very worried academics because
obviously it's the ideal if
formally we can demonstrate that his
that his that his model of this plan will
never be it's ideal but  as was
rightly said this morning by Mr.
because bus perfection is not of this
world and it will be necessary at least to try to
characterize the performances so
here with these tools there we have a means
of characterizing the robustness quite formally
of a system so see we
give its model we give an idea of the learn
ng database and raymond forma
ly indicates how we can vary
round these data which were used
uring learning and accor
ing to that it is a  able to
characterize a robustness and the level
of repeatability so that we also have
consequences with a partner
it can be a problem which is a tool
that we are in the process of evaluating once
again what we want to see it  and  st if this
tool which works well on paper it
will apply to our real cases is it
because too often we will force ourselves to
find a case that there is a tool which
highlights the site there it is  on the contrary
we really want with our use case to
check which tools work and there
we see three points we will
talk about it again so to hear that the workshop
on nutmeg white satin country
when flowers are not the subject
read on  other cases of the face then
French perceives that
formal demonstration on the images
that the problems of dimension that
quotes manuals this morning it works well on
the popular system mice with
small dimensions of tata and when
we did without these very beautiful tools of the cea
on images even when they are not
huge how does it not apply on the
other hand it applies very well
certain tools we also part
of the recommendations of confidence becomes
on data tactics we
recommend the city do not try  not these
tools it works pacing club
for now it's gone and then we will have an
academic type state which which are
produced again there we have to
find the scales uses which what
would be good it's tools in the  occurrence
all that is on get model did not
extend very long on the on no
model and it is replace standards and
look up tempo which had gigantic and
by a neural network which is
much smaller and how to
formally show that  so there's really
not too much information so there are
formal ways to demonstrate his haste
he did it and we have lots of other
tools to test on the subject so that
's what we can provide to  the end
of the year
but here we see another way then
is to be more locally can give
us a formal demonstration by
making guarantees in the credits on
the operation of the model we can
also make attacks much more
local and aulas is closer to  s
automatic methods where we are going to
put a noise at the entrance had to see
what is happening at the moment ti so we are going to
do that on the on the director of the
theaters of the opposing attacks by
adding noise by applying met
amortizations it's all kinds of
ways to vary the inputs
around the data on which we
did the learning and to see how
it starts to behave
on arrival so again beijing and
interests will be well represented in
the workshops  there so I invite you to
come and see and then if I just had
something that we won't talk about it's
on this famous use cases of classics
on agassi on it so it's more than that
means but rises to detect the
risks  of collision between two drones
and therefore we have large tables which
take the speed the
relative position vitality drones and which say that
they give advice on what
to do if we can continue to
turn right or  left don  c
go down and if we see that we were
not going what the ceva did is
to imply a symmetry simply
on the images that came in and to
check if we still found the
same outputs as in the initial base
and  we realize that there if we take
classic tools that we lose a lot
so we arrive at
success percentage alleys which are 32% 21% it's not
great so there we redid a job here
and we  sees that murray is much
less much better robustness in with
with these tools there so we evaluated the
robustness of a new guard again
of a new
network explain it empowered so once
again the explain it agitated there will be that
will be well exposed presented earlier
on the renault husky
there we are going we used a lot
of tools that come out of 10 so from this
famous neo project who you are and not
badly presented this morning so there are some
a lot of rana things from this year
we said to ourselves we will use his tools which
are  rtent dean and see if they work well
tell the times the project rather to me I
'll start there and so how
everything that was produced on the island and
even if we really want to use it on
our tools and so  there we want to be
there on which use of see there and we
will be able to give an output to each to
each industrialist on this type of use case
of the tools that come out of the island are
actually usable or not and then
after this concert obviously  we're not
the only ones so a set that was
blocked a bit empty this morning we're
not the only ones working on all these
trust topics all the
ladies guys they didn't wait for us and
they're producing stuff  huge and therefore
of all the little ones that gilles we close
we have identified them they are well
grouped blinds are there and we will
also test them and compare them to the others
and maybe we will not say for what
use the microsoft thing is  much
better than what we did out of 10
should be  be
open all the same and so we are going to make
this comparison on even who
abuse the tools and the ranges and
ours and then see this curious what it
gives
us are ready to hear it say 20 here
is nineteen it's nice but  it's
still less good than what you
already have at google or at home at
another one so here's multivalent how it
looks like inextricabilis and you
know it's good we're going to ask the
system for example on the traitor
images how it has  made his decision
to say that there was a pedestrian
so the way that he illustrated well
the classic case of the explain
able who does not walk to you
know it is that one recognizes me a
wolf dog with the  system recognized
in china a look it's a wolf because
he is one of the displays so there we would have
had in pixels for example we could
have explained if the system was not
sure explains inhabited would have said here  i
connect there is so it was a
car next there is  always worrying
everyone the explanation to the English henry
bas they go there he made his decision
only for the wrong reasons
so the
uncertainty reduction part good there again it
will be presented quite a bit this afternoon
so we are going to work a lot  on the
on the series sizes so it will be
presented in the workshop this afternoon
and there is a subject on which we also want to
work for sure so the
series tags be sure that it was given
numerically and therefore their me well  I
predict that the consumption will be
time with 30 agree 10:04
so that's it we can see clearly on the other hand on the
images what does it mean to
make predictions of uncertainty
so we are going to do that we are waiting for the case
of use of thalassa on the
recognition of photos in passing a
little spade to our friends here is to provide a
case of use of aerial photos here is
everyone we saw full time it is
quite difficult to find
formalize the rates to have the  res  water
which it's going well so we have it we are
waiting for this data in the meantime we
learned other flying machines learned
the flying squirrels for japan will do
action domain transfer and the
flying new planes but so
as  something there all the
entries but apart from here we see that
it breaks the uncertainties is that we have
several classes and we will be able
to say its part setha the object from
the classes is true that such a percentage
of  guarantee that's the thing on what
so runaway should be able to
provide tools by the end of the year and
finally the monitoring so I monitor
that it's a bit the part
started its tests the suspenders it's
redundancy and what can be
put in parallel with your system to
ensure that it worked well
so we were going to validate sent there are
employees of the tv networks to them so
unreasonable
I can't  explain the variation in
togo of hour streamer which is a tool
the ceva which is going to be tested on the
series stage we will represent later the
detection of the aude is then all
sale you know the difference
between running in and on time
ok I'm not doing it again so we have to do a
lot of  break in when we had our
stomachs and on the aude and
help them here as we can test
with rules it's on rules that will
be able to roughly say
normally at the exit I rather expect
this kind of thing  and we're going at least
like that it will succeed in is vague and
the big mistakes that a
data-based system would have made with
simple rules by a stop sign a no-entry
sign it's generally
red for simon system tell me that this  it
's not a wave it's a
speed limit sign or if these
red lines here is my rule can tell me
you're wrong we can
also have loans were used
what happens inside have
a few stand out a few ind  ications
about the activation of certain neurons
that's what it's something
that valeo is working on having some
indications of the
inner workings of the
network we can tell their networks
and in good dispositions
it looks like  work well or else there is
little to mark its operation
so here we are starting to get a little closer
to the gray box 1 it is good that
we must already have a little access to what is
happening inside  whereas for what
they had before one can have a
completely black lane buy you an
off grid box outside it's
because they love don't know how
it was driven nevertheless with
some business rules or with  another
brilliant back-to-school network is
still not seeing them monitor what
this box is doing see there we are starting to get
into fakes have a few hands
on the system
and then in the long term here it is again in our
rona pandora in the  years later we
in the  on pages 2 and 3 we can be
more interested in white boxes
to get in really me are
really hands in the box in their
euro zone we can still afford to
do other things for for told me
the recent operation
who we have a background work on
the evaluation of the monitoring it is necessary
itself this monitoring what confidence we
can bring in the monitoring
because it never stops once you
have a site with shoes worth
is what you trust  in the
proctor of a new question he
never stops and we try to get
answers to these questions
the past on here it is so i'm going to
pass my hand now on close that he's
going to talk about the part doing
directly well like  that we won't
need who characterizes and
his death
we on my side so
we are talking about the cost of life
of trust artificial intelligence algorithms already the first question
is what is this trust in
particular  nt with regard to the various
algorithms are consumed this objective
all the stake the first of the
activity rises here
therefore then
presented its
patronage plc aim believes
already certified which have been identified
works
by trying in a first time of
work therefore at the  state of the bank while
trying to adopt use the prism
oral tale and habib okuda first
activity so as to know in the end
what we are looking for in all
the animals is available and
then therefore make a pre-selection one
teaches fall and brings some
confidence credits so as to
apply them on which usages and
I stung her to evacuate them
naturally and finally bull but with
nine
complementary to ducks
at the apcdd1 gene for you
never started the part of the  group
of insurance that this notion of
trust so we will find in particular
for example which words rations to make
the ference and because already seen today
for example the  robustness and leave
to explain
the rules and very precisely we are
used to the state of the art
and
therefore suddenly
at the end of this first phase of
the state of the art we have that is to say
5 34 go
promising precisely the algorithm
that gave birth to the active lookout and
there we clicked precisely if one or
more
ways to go mature and and finally
the long-term objective of each and that's
that amazes me  to provide any brick that
would wash fit
trust launch glory with annie will need in any
case diagnosed position
until you can also a report of
this city boscail situation
it's very important also it's aubry
who  I also think in the long term of all
this activity of colonization and
mutilation this method in a way of
having extrapolated we will say the application
sure of us of
skateboarding sorry
[Music]
I left on board to head three
firsts
that we  are going to present the empty
actions and the activ  ities whose and sells
its
premises g4 everything is over and all
around the art of trust by solution
so first of all we will find therefore
the reverse training so the objective
here is to improve trust is there
role  it is to restore ron in the face of
adverse attacks only from an
empirical approach so in the end we will not be
able to say that the network is 100%
robust in this area and we will be
able to show how much the commands
behave much better
and  so we will perhaps get
into the technique a little bit that this test is
represented by rodolphe so the
principle of opposing training
is ground between on the one hand training the
neural network and on the other hand
generating examples  opponent and
inject them into the mode of learning
so there are methods that have been
identified in the state of
the art phase and the committee has recommended by quite a few
academic works including the
methods and gt and its variants
traditional methods  are not able to be etc
all these methods there we have
implemented them
with the aim of integrating
into an environment of trust and the
Swiss work in progress to test
this whole approach there is 4 of the
series but at the smig renault suddenly chip
is above its
c4 by bus or at the end of the match
concerning this loose action sheet so
then so we launched all
these young action which carries this road
movie this meeting is the
random listing so the objective here
unlike the presented sheet
previously it is to make the euro
robust in the face of all kinds of
disturbances not only adverse attacks
so it is an exact type approach
so it resembles in
principle the first of other forms it
however an advantage of the myths
doctorate named  tuxedo compared
to formal methods is that these
methods are much less expensive
is much more
scalable uncle expected for the end of the match
reims and to implement don  c all these
techniques there in two frameworks
of application classification and
also regression as on the first
part so there are a lot of
identical works and in the state of the art on the
other hand to adapt racing to
the aggression of  there it was necessary to do a
harmonic research work
so the expected is for the end of the
soft match 1 and it is the library
capacity the graff is also
the result of tests on these veterans of
the use the renault for the problem
as a genre comes a problem of
classification and the case of the
liquid albert or the major problem resurgence
of regulatory problems
so then we launched a quiche
to the insurgents on the generative models
so that these models was one of the
revolutions of linked to  in recent
years however, although these models
have not begun to be deployed quite badly
in the industry, the major communion
is that at least in the
original initial version these models are not
felt to be viable and d  so it is the
objective of this sheet to add to be interested
in baryons of erratic coding of m
so reliable
so the principle is instead of
having and predictions we will rather see
probabilities of solutions
probabilities forgiveness of its full models
we expect for the end of match 1
therefore a library implementation all that
compensate for these methods there and also
a feedback
the test on the case of the forbidden zebra
quay of the qualities a demotivation the
for  relaunch activities on its
models
pass the hand I dropped
then
[Music]
I'll take you suddenly it's
behind the brand was notably broken
the un is forced to consider the
constraints embark it empowered at
the design level of  first and this is the issue
here of those who work so
when it comes here
the objective here is the form
directly which 6-1 by the highways
which would be formatted in such a way as to be
embarked, that is to say  take it into
account beforehand  the design and
contrary to the allowances related for
example to the memory available to
embark randomly or the
capacity of the calculation is not often less
than to find you
the test
it is the objective here the work or to
do this it is necessary to alert the
learning algorithms in such a way as to
format them where we learn this type this
is the objective
that is expected to list the no
path for their objective is to
deliver this brick of confidence will be
with 2.3 algorithms are haunted  here
presented here is the case of the face which
is considerable and matic mature and
precisely this technique it is the
four areas of the acca above
finally besides the activity nani club
consider it so it is the apprentice
sand 2006  here the objective it has been
shown that the fact that the euro zone coach
in order to satisfy his
constant quest for kitsch there was first of all
very good feedback and you of the
robustness in the face of opposing attacks
and that another advantage  star  also to
set up this type of methodology
it is that the whole of the complexity
is rather deported from the camp of
the training during the installation
therefore an additional cost during the implementation
in fact we have a standard network
equal in  in any case your interest without being
considered
and therefore at the end of the low path of tiff
and books is therefore a first
increase in this method
of learning both on
classification problems and blu ray
therefore the case of the uses considered here
this is the case with the uses the constitution
so here to be really that we
know in the
major kodiak tools failing that I have
the impression that the industrialists
come looking for the perfect opportunity
tons is important and so on but
it's  this time we are going to offer here at the
end of the year this first method to
characterize your return network
that going to put it in your plane in
your car or so to say if you
leave will not be ten years old these
meth  odes there I know that I will have a
certain number of guarantees on the
operation
that by relying on developments
we already had almost at home
couture shelves we will be able to put
in the environment in a form that
will be packaged reusable look for it
at each of the manufacturers these first
tools and which will have been tested on
the premises what the book will be
of yesteryear in the environment of
living outside only things which have been
validated on a case of uses such as
the  'certified on that it works now
try finger on yours and then
you will tell me if it also
works it does not work so that's it we will learn a
lot with this effort that if each
industrialist can do outside the
project on the reuse what  have
provided it will be super super enriching
for gifted and we even hope that you
tell it it does not work because it means
that we still have things to
work on we hope to have
something  s success also a griot will
also say thank you for some cases but we
will also learn a lot of 2k that
don't work and I don't know
but really we are going against this year
we will have tools for you to test
in your environments
very withdrawal next
[Applause]
when  you promised so we
actually did the whole thing a little bit
with all edges blurred and all its
functions which allow design and
cutting and deploying the golden rice a
module ya in a base system there are
two questions  now
how do caps
finally to the module in the
system tale in mahdia
and this environment precisely in the
role of the very well said how
do I deploy it in my
industrial environment in which we are what I
am going to have to  the end of the year and
what have I been able to
implement to be able to get my hands on
the environment of trust
so to answer the first
question
I will app  eler d'aubagne who abandoned me
thank you so
I give them a little
layer on their empowered marks and I
will try to present what we see
at the political level to show that they
are surrounding where I can what we are
sees intervene for the moment
so in a short time a little aside
as was said this morning everything that
is proposed in two authorized brands
it started a little later your
projects
of course seen delivering alli on this thing
you  I'll talk right after and so
we see ourselves intervening
mainly as Jacques said
earlier in the design phase your
heart as soon as possible to avoid the
classic problems which are to
say I have a great group audiences
uppercut she well well I  've noticed
now that the most boring am super
happy and I can spend really a
lot of time trying to see
how I can best use it
while not knowing that I will ever arrive on
board correct  ment on - 1st
you want so
the first step is to intervene
in the red brick had evaluated m they
try during the design phase
we have
left according to godard wishes
on the mouth of the use we
want  go there a whole park of their
fears and we will have
the confidence environment that will be able to
give kids and you you have
invisible ended up saying I am one
of the components used the continuation
of using it fourth of ventilation
jesus tube
selected checkbox which  tell me to play
and hidalgo
the evangelist s of choice matrix who
tells me here is bercker if he was already going I
'm sure your equivalent model enough
on the point and then
depending on what was chosen
by the council than rather  going towards
small models is it possible
and therefore for that we need everything
that is components
of the designs and we need to know a
little bit beforehand like dp heaps of opportunities
claudel since who transp  ortera
sealed boxes willem and so i will
interrogate his petals and then i
got to guide the user on on
choice of target then then hand over
second brick or
to see ceb intervene which is
called model company
see in the  group is from the breeder is
more in the implementation part and
the idea is to be able to for good
all that is good tool all that she
does - and also gives to be
able to combine call it that from
my album on  the target that I will have
chosen
will tell you is once again between
the different brick patrols
aimed at the women in her brain with
for example different configurations
france comes out of all the models I have a
given configuration because I
gave and then info from the symposium
on the target is now the
godel compass I arrive and I know that they
touch the use and will do what to
use and hege coming directly from
making
the binaries available part do  nc for the box
it's rest of the
seven on the advice of explanation at the level
of what has been done what is planned for
this apple for the baccalaureate I paint as
jacques said everything in berlin where
we put the three big names of  my
interventions of the part in the parking lot
is sure it is that the event
presentation of an
execution generally it is
traditionally hollow more
to embark it not to reinvent the wheel and
to see if it is necessary to adapt what to
add  like a layer like public
which already exists
and in this sense which will be free at the end
of the year it is a first version of a
detail of general art on lombard quality
we resume in a first chapter it
is
what we know  their marks enabled
the classic constraints and then we
go for each patch according to the
theme of the match so lake major a
little earlier in the summer named we
did a big chapter on what to
bring in addition to power take into
account  precisely their  qualities of
rigor and the lobbies it is a kind
of analysts of 4 and of proposal of
solutions according to the constraints
place including and therefore if we speak a
little about part 10 to that we have
works today which  are on
the resource estimate
mainly
so everything that is the model enemy side
we have work on the
argument part obviously with a
sales look that will work on the say
execution time on my state of form
him who
is at the  level of the execution itself
so it got up which has not yet
left for the sale confidence and which
will be in amiens
in it's rather normal I know how
it is done once I have my bed you
would have  my favorite new models
how do I monitor the
system because once again what
we were saying this morning is that it is
interesting and if it is the
essential issue it is to be able to
embark animals
of machine learning in critical systems
and therefore there we  will use
everything that is the monitoring part that
will be produced
by their elders to see not a
title and the model this time it is
really the system steve
thank you
and suddenly I come back to the second
question which related to what  did
I finally get to the can and at the end they have
no path
so you will be able during this
presentation for each of the bricks in
particular because it starts each model
as looking like a monitor what
was planned for all  the components that
are planned by each of the projects and
that will be operational by the end
of the year
how I am in more than once
I arrive at the end of the year and
redeploy and their is applied
on  about kalisa plays my
internal environment and well in fact that's in
relation to what I mentioned, that is to
say that each of the components and
interoperable and modulate the bank
france or on each of these functions
of a movement n  of components
about  ant is interoperable with all
the other components of millions
before that means that I answer
survivors of course in fact that the
different data that circulates they
are recovered by the
next function by the next complement and
so on throughout the chain
road
is popular because in fact I
can extract just and your needs that
interests me compared to my face
compared to my case the explanation
apparently the environment and should
deploy in my
industrial environment in my victim environment
why c  is possible because in fact
this environment of trust it is based
on an execution environment
it is normal execution it serves two purposes
the first which serves
as a working environment
within the framework of the program therefore it is an
event  who lives available for
your and different projects can
attest to develop design the
models of the institutes from which the
head of the loc l'o benefits  rchestrator etc
allowing to manage the whole chain of
bye bye bye
to note the match enters the calcio
of a
whole chain here that you see
opposes the supplementing which are open
source and therefore it is necessary to recover well and
you can see them deploy for
to be able to reconstruct this would even be in a
runtime environment one of the
deliverables, moreover, in particular
on one of the projects, is to provide a
manual for deploying this
runtime environment
so that you are autonomous from  resume
should deposit and redeploy
over components
detailed specified and exposed
previously
auxi summarizes the the environment of
trust it is a set of
software components therefore the
official start of the applications of the libraries
of the scripts it is also a set
of gaye  likes and methodology to be
able to use them but also for
the moment barrels in on your own
well-being and relies on an
execution environment.  one on which google
press you to unlock the recover
the set is the king of taste fonts
or so only recover the
elements that interest us is gone
in its passes the work so there
I match storms to work it
as long as I conceive very  is that this
set of trust and execution
be agnostic of bad luck from
the infrastructure that can be
redeployed i find a
possible environment and it's a
work in progress
m whether it's in forty years
would apparently be 17  from
tables
in a few words a few we will remember
in an environment of trust it
is made up of components of the network
interoperable ecological component the
modular it is supported by
fellows and mythologies I want because
analytical it is articulated suddenly it
left this  lake the whole allows
to articulate michel
moutier closed this stick of the
caustic hay environment of the target architecture
is  stranded which should allow the design
the validation the ligament and the
online monitoring if possible one of the
wines of a mythical system of asgard
I am going to had seen a project there which is a
very broad very ambitious line there is a
German project which  equipped the same
size in terms of funding and which
only deal with the case of the pedestrian abbot
i.e. detecting a frantic pedestrian
so that's it so it's really fixed
super there and thanks to the organization which
was chosen the  cutting into packets into
tasks I prove that all this started
very quickly perhaps too quickly we did not
specify at length everything that
had to be done if we beat specified everything
we are going to do on four at the bottom we will
start  in four years to me lies so
we started a little in all directions
the energy between the people who arrive and
with wrestling buns was already ready
explains to test on the spot what
she sees stopping by rapper
of  essence that may have if you are
very attentive vo  You have seen that we were
sometimes presented with the same thing twice or three times
because we are all in
stained glass and on the sound effects of the
input data on the monitoring of the data
outside the distribution here but that is
rather nice so little by little  small by we
will discover bellac and we will take only
what has elsewhere but for me it is
good because it reflects the energy of
this group which wants to work and with
a dynamic for the closest to  them
from a small team only big big
boats only the wharf this project no I was
pushing recently
[Music]
because this project will
find people with experience there was
music here the truth that we meet
nowhere else
we have around  from the
discussion table people who are
specialists in algorithms people who
are specialists in engineering and people
who are specialists who are
researchers in there are people who are
specialists in domain safety and
all that is something that is the
for  this program confidence in the
night and the second force if it is that
this tight expertise changes is
managed through
transverse seminars which are places of
sharing
with a
very fluid scientific and technical coordination and which allows you
to advance all that  again so we hope
that the friends who will come in order to be
less than profitable and will give
thanks to that a lot of innovations
thank you and I wanted to end by
thanking patoul the whole ecosystem which
allowed this program to start off
well and we  left quickly that the
big things before I don't know
were present work produced by the
messier program the industry aggregation
sion others thank my bible to
the excellence of the ecosystem it's
Parisian that 25 lysians that Toulouse years
equal  between the two who each
played a game of sharing their recipes
and their elements just a quick word and
after I finally a little round of questions
about the organization which has two has  thematic workshops
which will explore a little
more the side either methodologies are
equipped that you have one in
introduction just now and two
workshops which are coming will unfold from start
to finish the yungas that as we have seen
the important on useless and  to have the
confidence of everything in pink
and so it's the way to show your
age calculations and of course we will be delighted
to have all your feedback